Hey, hello and welcome to another video.
This one is an ongoing story that I'm working on
I think it's quite the scoop
I've never talked about this before
So it might come.. quite as a shock!
..
The media
is stupid.
GOT 'EM *Wheezes*
Parenthesis
not all media, just clickbait media
OH BOY.
Where did it all go wrong?
Just like you,
I get my news from the internet.
From the-- from the inter-webs
That's where I find my information
on what's going on in the world
That's how I find out
what is going on
on the next PewDiePie video.
If you look on Google News,
Essentially, there's a bunch of different news outlets.
We got The Sun, we got The Guardian,
we got BBC, we got WIRED, Forbes.
They're all essentially competing with each other.
The basic -- OHOH shit okay-- well this is a good
title; I guess I'll click on that one.
Oh, how 'bout that there's an ad there.
Okay. Great.
So essentially, as soon as I click, they get paid.
It doesn't really matter what the content is.
As long as they have a good enough--strong enough title
Y-know, that beats all it's competitors.
Then they get paid. So, really, the content
is pretty much irrelevant. They just need a strong title
no matter what.
And I know what you're thinking.
You might be like "Ohkay, well Felix, you're on YouTube,
everyone clicks-bait on YouTube, but you're doing the same thing."
No.
Not really. It's kinda different.
First of all, YouTube monitors watch time.
So, even if you have a clickbait video, and people don't actually watch it
It won't get as promoted.
YouTube has been promoting watch time more than anything since 2014.
Allegedly — that's what they say at least.
It's the first thing that appears if you click on your analytics.
Literally, you go to analytics, first thing that appears, watch time.
A hundred and fifty thousand years.
*chuckles* you guys spend watching my videos.
That's just kinda sad, isn't it?
But also, a very important distinction,
is that YouTube is entertainment.
Media... is the fucking news.
It's supposed to give you an objective standpoint
on-- and tell people, what is going on out there,
it's the truth, y'know.
I think this is a bigger problem than a lot of people realise.
Because it d-- it affects actual people.
It affects reality.
It affects people like ME.
And I think that's why I've been bitching about it so much.
Anyway, uhm, remember when the news was sent to your home?
That was basically... subscription-based.
So, the media would get paid regardless.
So basically, they didn't have to clickbait.
Uhh, to get paid.
And that way you get a more unbiased... uhmm, objective news.
You could say, hey maybe you could actually get the truth.
Instead of this where whoever yells the loudest, gets paid.
Now, 2017 is the year..it's gonna go bad for me.
Alright, I'm just calling it out right now.
You want, you--- get out before you can't.
Because PewDiePie is... he's a badboy now.
He's uhmm... he's a meanie.
He's terrible. Ughh!
He's racist,
homophobic,
anti semitic,
huh, what other labels can we put him..
Hitler-loving
Uhmm
White...
You may have noticed that it's been a lot of
articles, popping up, around me lately.
I'm just gonna put it out there and say, 90% of them are negative.
The media, wants to pick me as some sort of villain.
BRINGITON
Now please, please stop...it's really annoying. (Yes, it is)
It's confusing old friends that don't pay attention to what I'm doing anymore.
They're like... wait, you're racist now? I don't understand.
'Cause that's the problem isn't it?
Unless you really know me and what I do, and you read these titles about me,
you're obviously gonna believe what they're saying.
And people just read the title anyway.
They just wanna put those labels out there... anti semitic, racist...
we -- he -- said the N word.
All those kinds of shit.
That's all that matters.
Because that's how they get paid.
My goal is not to keep pushing these controversial topics.
What I just think, and I-I believe strongly in
is that
it's 2017 now. We've got to have to start separating
what- what is a joke, and what is actually problematic
Is-or what actually fulfills the label of whatever you're calling it.
Is a joke actually pure racism?
Is a jo-- Is something that would be considered joke actually pure homophobic?
or all--ehh anti semitic, and all these things
Context-fucking matters
Titles will never explain contents.
And that's the problem with all my videos lately
Is that, they take all these stuff that I say
out of context, because that's what's gonna get them clicks.
And that's gonna get them ads
Which is gonna get them money.
"PewDiePie in Anti-Semitic storm after paying men to unveil sign stating 'death to all Jews' hits YouTube."
Y'know, and they report on this, and clearly, everyone is outraged.
It's a-- it's a huge controversy.
International Business Times. The fuck does that have to do with my content?
It's almost like polygon or kotaku sitting in the corner of my videos.
Be like, C'monnn!!! Say something bad about gaming so we can get in on this shit.
International Business Times, like, what the fuck are you talking about?
See, and even all the comments talked about it, like
"What a trash article. Nice grab for views you hacks."
I'm glad people at least realise
And I'm, I'm really glad to see that the majority realise how bullshit these articles are.
And that they fulfill no purpose, whatsoever
than to tear down my name.
To get some more clicks online.
So basically, for those who don't know what happened,
Uhmm, I was fucking around with this website, we can pay people
to make messages.
And most people said no to my request, there was a girl that was supposed to play
hearthstone with me and I asked her to play roblox
And she was like, no.
And uhh, that's how she didn't fulfill the request.
There was another person that was supposed to do a penis in a math graph
And they said no.... and
Well, for some fucking reason, these Indian guys
actually went ahead and wrote 'Death to All Jews' on a sign
Which, y'know, there's something funny about that.
At least, y'know, it might be just my rude sense of humour
but I think there's something funny about that.
And I don't think there's any actual anti-semitic thing
about it. Again, I think there's a difference between a joke
and actual, like, fucking 'Death to All Jews'
If I made a video, saying, 'Hey guys, uh, PewDiePie here,
death to all jews. I want you to say after me
'death to all jews'
and uh, Hitler was right
I really opened my eyes to what power
and I think it's time that we did something about it."
That's essentially how they're reporting this
as if that's what I was saying or some shit like that
Another controversy was this five year old
that I made uhhh, made fun of.
"PewDiePie hates on rival channel which stars a fiver year old."
No, I didn't make fun of the five year old. I made fun of
the mother running the channel
But you know, that's not an appealing title, is it?
That doesn't get you as much views as
PEWDIEPIE FUCKED UP A FIVE YEAR OLD
PEWDIEPIE JUST  WENT RIGHT IN ON THAT FIVE YEAR OLD
That poor five year old- *childish voice* "ehh don't do it pewdiepie!"
FUCK YOU FIVE YEAR OLD
And if you actually watched the video,
you would understand.
That I'm not making fun of the kid
Uh, but that doesn't matter, does it?
It really doesn't matter. At least not in the title.
And you know what, to the benefit of the articles, usually do mention it somewhere along this fucking ?? of text
But that doesn't really matter because the title
is what people read. That's what 90% of what people actually read.
Another big controversy, Ye-yes I know there's been a lot of them.
uh, was me, slipping the N word in one of my videos
Basically, I got excited about becoming a
ranked 18 most handsome. And I went
18 NI-
And then it cut off before I even said the whole thing
But news articles, of course, loving a bit of controversy,
The Sun put it as "PewDiePie slammed after appearing to say.." I love this censoring.
If you gonna say it, just fucking say it.
Context matters.
It's 2017 now.
I think it's time for change.
Okay.
I know it's bad, I know it's gonna cause controversy.
It kinda just slipped out, cause all my videos are improvised.
And I saw through editing, I thought it was funny with the way it was used.
Clearly, a bad call from my part, and I'm not gonna use it again
mainly, not because I care if the word is bad or not,
It's because, people.. it just causes people to lose their
fucking mind. And it's just not worth it.
Like I don't get a kick out of all these controversy.
It's not something that I just feel like, "OHFUCKYEAH LOOKATALLTHESEATTENTIONTHATI'MGETTING"
I'm not trying to push the envelope.
I'm just trying to stay true to my sense of humour. And I'm not actually
trying to offend people with what I'm doing.
Believe it or not.
You know if people are offended, that's kinda like, well, that sucks for you.
I feel like I'm digging myself a grave this whole *cracks voice* video.
But it think it's worth talking about, so don't get me wrong.
If I do something bad, and if I do something actually racist.
Or actually homophobic.
Or actually with the intend of it.
I do believe I should be held accountable. I'm not
saying that all media
They're not allowed to criticise me
'cause I'm perfect
and my perspective is always what's better.
If I do, shit I should be called out for
clearly, I have noth- I have no problem with that.
But I don't think this is it. And I really truly believe that
These uhh articles, slamming uhh
slamming people like me
for these topics, they're doing more harm than good
They're doing more harm than I'm doing.
By saying them, I think.
I think being the political correctness police is essentially just gonna fuck us all over
and this year 2017, I've decided, I'm taking stands back. I'm gonna
be true to myself. I wanna do this sense of humour that I enjoy
and uhm, this is the price for it. I'm fine with that
This video has really no point
and you guys- an- all- and I'm kinda preaching to the choir right now
I just wanna say thanks
for seeing through the bullshit
I read the comments, I see that you guys
see- see through the bullshit
ehhhh- an- and criticize just like I'm doing right now
and i think that's...
I think that's really cool. Thank you
Appreciate that *kiss*
*reads the text on screen*
Heyyyy
It's almost like there's real, actual issues out in the world
That you can actually care about
Instead of-
Instead of whether a YouTuber
Makes slightly edgy jokes
and it's like- I'm just barely-
This is like the standard on the internet anyway, like-
People literally just care because I'm PewDiePie
an- when ew- en en
whatever I do is just gonna be a fuckin news article...
...about it
But literally anyone else can say it and no one gives a shit
I wonder what articles there's gonna be about this video
uh
PewDiePie defends himself after-
after saying the N word
PewDiePie is essentially Hitler now
Well...
Hopefully I wont have to talk about this anymore
I'm getting kind of tired of it
I just wanted to set the record straight
That's all.